[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde les nouveaux pauvres en France
et dans le monde
contrairement aux idées reçues la
pauvreté en valeur absolue n'est pas en
augmentation constante pas plus en
France que dans le monde mais une fois
ce constat posé dès que l'on décline
l'évolution du niveau de vie le taux de
pauvreté les inégalités de revenus ou de
patrimoine le niveau d'éducation et que
l'on reporte ces facteurs au lieu de
résidence à la situation professionnelle
au contexte familial et à une kyrielle
de désagrément sociaux culturel nous
constatons alors une explosion des
disparités qui en s'accumulant vont
créer des situations de malaises
sociales aggravés d'insécurité un
sentiment d'abandon et d'injustice
d'humiliation aussi au cours de cette
émission nous porterons notre regard
sur la France et le reste du monde ainsi
que sur l'Europe moins pour relativiser
la gravité d'une situation locale que
pour chercher à comprendre pourquoi dans
nos sociétés d'abondance nous n'arrivons
pas à éradiquer ce fléau quasi endémique
qui constitue qui constitué par la
pauvreté et comment en réduire les
conséquences sociales économiques
culturelles et sanitaire avec mes
invités nous allons chercher à y
répondre Hélène pesquine vous êtes
architecte
urbaniste de l'État secrétaire
permanente du Puka Philippe Douste Blazy
vous êtes ancien ministre des Affaires
étrangères et président de unitlife nous
dirait ce que ça veut dire Hervé Le Braz
vous êtes démographe et historien à qui
melkar oui vous êtes consultant à
Montaigne ainsi que Montaigne et
politologue
[Musique]
alors pour commencer d'abord un état des
lieux en France Hervé Le brasse près de
1300 quartiers pauvres pour une
population de pauvres estimée à 5
millions de personnes finalement de quoi
s'agit-il c'est 5 millions c'est
quartier voilà faut déjà voir 5 millions
c'est quand on compte les personnes qui
sont
qui sont à 50% du ce qu'on appelle le
revenu médian c'est-à-dire le revenu tel
que la moitié des Français gagnent plus
et l'autre moitié moins mais si on prend
50% en dessous voilà mais si on prend de
plus en plus on prend 60% et du coup le
nombre de pouces monte à 8 millions donc
il y a une certaine c'est assez relative
cette
ce que vous avez dit au début
c'est absolument frappant parce que
contraire l'opinion qu'on les Français
c'est qu'en fait jusqu'au dernier
chiffre de l'Insee la breté n'a pas
augmenté en France la rentrée dans le
détail oui alors bien sûr elle a
beaucoup diminué jusque disons
mais il y a un point il y a un point
important par rapport à vous remarquer
initiales c'est que ça me rappelle
c'est pas c'est pas parce qu'il y aura
une stabilité ou même moins de pauvres
que l'opinion et les Français se
sentiront en état d'égalité c'est même
le contraire est dans Tocqueville déjà
Tocqueville fait cette remarque quand il
parcourt les États-Unis il est étonné il
dit plus il y a d'égalité plus il y a de
mécontentement de la population et de
sentiments d'inégalité et je pense que
c'est un point très important pour
comprendre les problèmes de pauvreté
d'inégalités ce n'est pas
malheureusement en diminuant ces
questions qu'il faut bien sûr diminuer
la pauvreté aller vers plus d'égalité
mais il faut s'attendre malgré tout à ce
que en permanence
il y ait une insatisfaction à ce sujet
écoutez très précisément Hélène
pesquille parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
questions qui se posent et on va pas
tout aborder en même temps mais très
précisément
ces millions de pauvres c'est 1300
pardon comme c'est plus que 1300
quartiers pauvres est-ce que votre avis
comment s'est réparti territorialement
alors ces statistiques l'observateur des
inégalités et les différentes
statistiques le montrent la pauvreté est
plus forte dans les villes la majorité
des pauvres habitent dans les villes et
notamment dans les quartiers dit
populaire je pense qu'on y reviendra qui
sont des quartiers concentrateurs de
population et de ménage modestes et très
modestes mais il y a aussi une pauvreté
rurale de plus en plus d'ailleurs on la
met en avant alors quantitativement
contenu de la démographie et du fait
qu'il y a peu de population dans
l'espace rural c'est pas énormément de
gens mais c'est assez spécifique et il y
a aussi des choses à des questions à se
poser et peut-être des politiques à
imaginer un peu dédié à cette pauvreté
rurale qui est en plus c'est très
impactée elle par les notions de
précarité énergétique notamment dans des
logements on va rentrer dans le détail
mais évidemment la majorité des gens
pauvres en France qui sont donc vous
dites dans les villes mais est-ce que
c'est plus des grandes villes dans le
centre de la France qu'en Bretagne
est-ce que c'est plus au sud est-ce que
comment vous
sur ce point là je pense qu'il y avait
le brasse aura des données plus précises
en tout cas c'est majoritairement dans
les grandes villes dans les quartiers
alors je les appelle les quartiers
populaires ceux qui sont notamment visés
par la politique de la ville les grands
ensembles mais aussi les centres anciens
dégradés plutôt se démétropoles ou des
métropoles régionales Paris bien sûr
mais aussi dans toutes les régions de
France il y a des métropoles Toulouse
Nantes Bordeaux Marseille évidemment des
très grosses différences régionales les
disons la pauvreté en France c'est le
chapeau nord de la France la frontière
nord-est et puis toute la zone
méditerranéenne ça va ça va pratiquement
du simple eau double quand on passe des
départements qui justement les moins
pauvres qui est la Vendée d'ailleurs une
partie de l'Ouest quand on va ensuite
vers l'Aude vers le Roussillon donc les
différences sont fortes et elles ont des
conséquences politiques parce que la
carte de la pauvreté correspond aux
grandes parties il faut le dire à la
carte des résultats du rassemblement
national oui bon on va rentrer dans
cette considération politique à qui mais
le car oui est-ce que on peut tirer une
un message de ce qui vient d'être dit
c'est-à-dire que cette pauvreté comme ça
qui se répartit territorialement est-ce
qu'elle signifie quelque chose c'est à
dire
si dans le Cantal il y a plus de pauvres
qu'en Bretagne il y a une
prédétermination ou quelque chose comme
ça est-ce que en somme si on est pauvres
on reste pauvre en fonction du
territoire je crois qu'il y a vraiment
deux catégories de situations il y a les
catégories rurales on en parlait les
quatre catégories urbaines dans les
campagnes la pauvreté c'est une pauvreté
de toute petite exploitation de services
à faible valeur ajoutée et de déprises
rurales de des prises démographiques
dans les grandes villes c'est
complètement différent c'est une
pauvreté où il y a beaucoup
d'immigration et si une pauvreté qui se
renouvelle parce que dès que notamment
les immigrés il y a pas que des immigrés
mais quartier politique de la ville le
taux de pauvreté c'est 40%. le moyen
c'est 15% passage les retraités c'est
7%. dans ces quartiers là il y a un
renouvellement de la population qui est
important et donc c'est des gens qui
arrivent pauvres qui travaillent
beaucoup travaillent contrairement aux
idées que qu'on en a et puis dès qu'ils
accumulent un peu de capital ils partent
c'est une pauvreté de stabilité la
pauvreté dans les grandes villes c'est
d'une certaine mesure une pauvreté qui
est quand même en mouvement donc il vaut
mieux être pauvre dans une grande ville
que dans les campagnes oui alors
Philippe dose de blaziers avec vous je
voudrais poser la même question au
niveau mondial mais
j'oublie pas que vous avez été médecin
vous êtes toujours médecin j'oublie pas
que vous avez été maire de Lourdes à
votre avis est-ce qu'il y a un ressenti
de pauvreté plus grand quand on est dans
certains territoires que dans d'autres
parce que il n'y a pas comment dire le
taux eubohu du mouvement culturel etc
oui bien évidemment au moment où les
réseaux sociaux exposent vous comprenez
bien que tout le monde regarde tout le
monde et donc il y a ce sentiment
d'injustice ou même d'humiliation
puisque c'est le mot que vous avez
employé tout à l'heure au niveau mondial
déjà les définitions sont pas toujours
les mêmes d'abord c'est le revenu bien
sûr et là le revenu c'est 1, 90 euros ou
dollar ce qui est même chose par jour
dans les pays les plus pauvres c'est la
Banque mondiale et la communauté
internationale qui ont défini cela en
fonction du revenu médian des 15 pays
des plus pauvres dans le monde
il y a je dirais 720 millions de
personnes qui peuvent être considérés
comme celle-là ensuite vous avez un
million sur 8 ou 9 milliards mais
ensuite vous avez les pays pour répondre
à votre question à moyenvue la c'est pas
1,9 c'est 3,2 euros par jour qui
considérait comme le seuil de pauvreté
puis il y a le CDE comme notre pays ce
qui va être Monsieur Le Braz c'est à
dire que là c'est 1063 euros par mois ce
qui correspond à 60% du revenu médian
mais pensez que on va définir la
pauvreté uniquement par le revenu est
une erreur il y a aussi d'autres
éléments le plus important par rapport à
votre introduction c'est l'accès au bien
public mondiaux c'est-à-dire la
nourriture et on parlera d'un
malnutrition tout à l'heure en parler
l'eau potable les droits à la santé des
choses aussi aussi élémentaires que la
vaccination
l'assainissement il faut savoir que la
première raison de mortalité des enfants
aujourd'hui c'est la diarrhée parce
qu'il boivent de l'eau sale et enfin
bien sûr l'éducation qui est absolument
majeure en particulier pour les filles
et dernier point je voudrais le dire à
titre personnel parce que je me suis
présenté au point de directeur général
de l'OMS et j'ai été battu d'ailleurs
mais sur ce sujet je pense que le fait
que 4 milliards d'individus aujourd'hui
non pas de protection sociale et
certainement la honte de l'humanité
aujourd'hui donc oui l'accès la
protection sociale est déjà un facteur
tout à fait
que on s'en tienne pas au PNB mais qu'on
intègre dedans des questions de
bien-être d'éducation et de santé mais
alors on va faire au cours de cette
émission on va passer en permanence de
la France et du monde je voudrais vous
poser une question politique qui met le
Karoui et c'est exactement comme en
matière de pauvreté la France est si
l'on peut dire mieux loti que les autres
pays européens et que le taux de
pauvreté en France même durant la
pandémie a été contenue grâce au
quoiqu'il en coûte et d'ailleurs après
sa réexplosé c'est exact il y a le quoi
qu'il en coûte mais il y a surtout tout
le système de protection sociale et la
redistribution donc la France est un
pays qui est très inégalitaire avant la
redistribution mais qui est parmi les
plus inégalités les plus égalitaires de
l'OCDE après redistribution donc les
impôts les charges sociales ça sert à
quelque chose
donc vous pensez que c'est ça qui a
permis d'atténuer le choc c'est ce qui
structurellement permet d'atténuer les
inégalités et d'avoir un taux de
pauvreté qui est pas satisfaisant mais
qui est moins pire qu'ailleurs alors
avec vous Hélène pesquine vous qui vous
penchez sur les territoires
la pauvreté finalement ça recouvre
beaucoup de choses alors pour beaucoup
de pour les gens ça veut dire des
invisibles des gens du voyage des
ordinaires des petits blancs des
populations racisées des migrants bref
délaissés pour compte on a même parlé à
propos des gilets jaunes de nouveaux
pauvres tout simplement finalement c'est
quoi les pauvres si c'est tout ça parce
que quand il y a un fourre-tout ça veut
tout dire et rien dire
en dehors de la statistique et en dehors
de de du taux médian etc il y a les
définitions statistiques elles comptent
quand même absolument
tous les gens qui se vue dans ce que je
viens d'énumérer se considère comme des
pauvres on peut considérer qu'elle a la
pauvreté absolue c'est à dire monétaire
effectivement en termes de revenus 40%,
50% du revenu médian en France et ça
définit la pauvreté dans des voilà dans
des normes qui sont comparables à
d'autres pays occidentaux notamment et
puis on pourrait appeler ça à la
pauvreté relative c'est-à-dire le fait
de se trouver dans un système
inégalitaire en tout cas qui est
ressenti comme très inégalitaire entre
des très riches et des moins riches
c'est justement le cas de ces 60% de
pauvres qui vivent dans les grandes
villes c'est qu'ils sont entourées de
très riches à l'inverse des pauvres qui
vivent dans la ruralité et qui sont des
gens avec des revenus modestes mais dans
un système territorial ou le revenu
moyen finalement est plus faible donc il
y a moins de de d'inégalités entre les
plus riches et les plus pauvres donc il
y a déjà des ressentis très différents
et quand on commence à parler de cette
pauvreté relative au ressentie on rentre
dans la notion de pouvoir d'achat et la
difficulté surtout en période
d'inflation comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui à se comparer enfin à
l'accélération de ses revenus ou
l'augmentation de ses revenus parce
qu'ils sont plutôt continue en tout cas
moyenne à l'augmentation l'accélération
des prix et donc à se sentir un peu
déclassé en tout cas en situation de
devenir plus pauvre si on n'est pas
pauvre sans statistique on se sent
devenir plus pauvre par rapport à
d'autres et par rapport à un pouvoir
d'achat qu'on estime être ce lieu auquel
on pourrait aspirer en termes de
classes sociales du niveau de d'emploi
parce qu'on parle maintenant beaucoup de
travailleurs pauvres jusqu'à récemment
il peut y avoir de la pauvreté chez les
gens qui sont un peu à l'écart de
l'emploi soit des retraités soit des
jeunes qui rentrent ou avant qui rentre
dans l'emploi aujourd'hui on a aussi des
gens qui travaillent et c'est tout le
symbole un peu porté par le début par le
mouvement des gilets jaunes des gens qui
n'arrivent pas à joindre les deux bouts
alors qu'ils ont un travail et
finalement un niveau de revenus qui
n'est pas si faible que ça comparé à des
gens très très modestes qu'on trouve
notamment dans les quartiers populaires
des grandes villes alors justement sur
cette question du déclassement Philippe
Doste Blazy vous voyagez beaucoup en
tout cas entre la France et les
États-Unis vous savez qu'on dit que tout
le le mouvement vogue etc
multiculturelle serait importé des
États-Unis mais c'est une autre
discussion mais à votre avis
ce sentiment de pauvreté de déclassement
vous pensez que il est plus de l'ordre
du ressenti par exemple les gens se
sentent invisibles parce qu'ils passent
pas à la télévision parce que on parle
pas d'eux est-ce que ce déclassement là
vous le vous le voyez comme un élément
d'injustice culturel Laurent bouvé par
les d'insécurité culturelle ou est-ce
qu'il vous paraît revêtir quelque chose
de réel dans nos sociétés
occidentales
c'est-à-dire que la pauvreté c'est vous
savez le 17 octobre 1992 autre cadero il
y avait 100 000 personnes le jour le
premier jour international de la lutte
contre la pauvreté
ils ont décidé c'est écrit dans la dalle
du Trocadéro c'est une violation des
droits de l'homme donc on parlez des
pays les plus pauvres non je non je
parle des gens pauvres en France il y a
aujourd'hui vous savez la pauvreté le
président Lula m'avait dit un jour tu
sais il y a deux sortes de personnes
dans la vie il y a ceux qui ont connu la
fin et ceux qui n'ont pas connu la fin
et personne ne peut parler de la fin
comme ceux qui n'ont connu moi je les ai
pas connu j'ai pas connu l'extrême
pauvreté ce que je sais c'est qu'en
France il y a de très gros pauvres et ça
ça on ne peut pas pardon Emile Mallet je
connais vos valeurs mais on ne peut pas
dire que ce sont des gens qui croient
être pauvres alors qu'ils ne sont pas
non il y a des pauvres en France c'est
terrible c'est dramatique je vais vous
prendre un exemple que je connais bien
prenez une maman
qui a deux enfants son mari est parti
elle est dans la banlieue elle gagne
donc à des caissières à mi-temps elle a
800 euros par mois elle va au
supermarché elle va d'abord commencer
par la viande pour les enfants et elle
va bien
et au bout d'un an si jamais elle est
encore enceinte alors elle sera
malnutrit chronique et son enfant aura
des séquelles cérébrales mais ça ça
existe en France
on vient de le dire
par rapport à certains pays mais mieux
lotis par rapport à d'autres non mais
c'est vrai mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que il y a toujours des exemples
l'émission elle est sur les nouveaux
pauvres les pauvres quand on dit les
pauvres ça se respecte un pauvre c'est
le mot pauvre et il doit être respecté
et donc je pense que les pauvres c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut à tout prix
d'une manière d'une autre c'est pas
uniquement donner de l'argent c'est une
sorte de dignité il faut trouver un
système pour que les personnes ne
sentent pas à l'extérieur l'exclusion
les associations qui travaillent
là-dessus sont exceptionnelles je leur
donne un grand coup de chapeau ça va des
petits frères des Pauvres à des Carmaux
en passant par les autres non les
pauvres ça existe en France il voulait
dire amour notamment il y a 20 % des
enfants qui vivent en France qui vivent
dans des familles sous le seuil de
pauvreté
20%, c'est c'est considérable
oui alors Hakim alkary je vais vous
poser une question qui peut paraître
polémique mais qu'il faut essayer
peut-être d'apporter du sang sinon de
trancher si on prend le mille-feuille
territorial avec l'urbain d'un côté le
rural de l'autre Hélène pesquine en a
parlé il y a différents niveaux
territoriaux et au sein de cette
archipelisation des territoires du
territoire une polémique s'est faite
jour entre la France périphérique
peuplée de petits blancs qui accumule
les désagréments et qui sont faut le
dire en situation très précaire avec les
banlieues où les migrants seraient mieux
lotis c'est vrai ou c'est faux
alors ça c'est Christophe guilhouy qui a
absolument ça et avec des publications
dans le niveau BC à chaque fois parce
que le premier était le premier livre
était intéressant puis après on est
tombé dans la caricature d'abord ça a
pas grand sens d'opposer les uns avec
les autres opposés des pauvres avec
d'autres pauvres
ensuite la France périphérique dont il
parle si on parle les gilets jaunes les
gilets jaunes il y en avait pas dans les
quartiers pauvres pourquoi parce que en
fait ils sont au dessus socialement de
des gens des quartiers pauvres leur
sujet c'est le déclassement c'est même
plutôt la peur du déclassement avec des
professions de service qui effectivement
pas beaucoup d'avenir et dont le niveau
social baisse enfin on a regardé avec
l'Institut Montaigne dans un rapport qui
s'appelle les quartiers pauvres ont un
avenir pardon je fais un peu de
publicité par exemple la répartition du
des fonctionnaires sur le territoire ce
qu'on voit c'est que à l'évidence la
France des gilets jaunes est infiniment
mieux servie que la France des quartiers
pauvres la différence c'est la densité
parce que dans la France périphérique et
ultra périphérique au sens de la
périphérie des villes la densité est
faible et donc l'accès aux services
publics paraît plus difficile parce que
pour aller au bureau de poste et bien il
faut faire quelques kilomètres quand
vous habitez à Aulnay-sous-Bois une
troisième commune la plus pauvre de
France le bureau de poste est plus
proche
géographiquement que quand vous habitez
dans la Creuse ça c'est vrai mais si
vous comptez le nombre de postiers le
nombre de policiers le nombre
d'enseignants le nombre de médecins par
habitant il y en a infiniment plus dans
la France par exemple ce qu'on appelle
la France du vide que dans la France des
grandes métropoles et notamment de les
quartiers pauvres des grandes métropoles
donc c'est faux un c'est faux et deux il
faut arrêter d'opposer les uns avec les
autres si on veut créer des oppositions
on regarde la France la plus riche et
les services publics qui sont destinés à
France la plus riche avec la France la
plus pauvre et on fait l'alliance des
pauvretés
vous avez tout à fait raison sur ce
point et il y a un autre point qui est
tout à fait raison mais pourquoi les
gens pensent le contraire ça c'est une
question pour des psychologues
un élément supplémentaire c'est que
quand on regarde quelle est
l'augmentation des revenus au cours des
20 dernières années donc on a une banque
de données remarquable les revenus ont
d'autant plus augmenté qu'on est dans le
rural profond l'endroit où les revenus
ont le plus augmenté au cours des 20
dernières années c'est le Cantal
l'anglais
dire ça aux agriculteurs vous allez voir
ils vont pas vous recevoir expliquer en
partie pourquoi mais ma question n'est
pas de savoir comment je serai ressenti
ma question c'est de regarder des faits
et ça c'est un fait et c'est un fait un
très bon fond géographique économiste et
le premier à l'avoir noté c'est Laurent
Davy il a fait un très bon travail sur
sur ce sujet mais c'est ça choque
tellement l'idée moi je me souviens que
quand j'ai fait les calculs quand j'ai
fait mes cartes j'ai pensé que je
m'étais trompé dans l'ordre des dates
que j'avais inversées
2019 et puis 1999 donc j'ai refait des
calculs à la main pour être persuadé que
je n'étais pas trompé donc vous êtes
tous d'accord pour considérer que c'est
des bobards que de dire que
les on est plus avantagés dans les
banlieues que dans la France
périphérique etc
tous les indicateurs statistiques
entre guillemets il y a aussi dirige
dans l'espace rural il y a aussi dirige
dans les grandes périphéries
urbaines et il y a donc il y a toute une
sorte de population qui se croisent
aussi dans ces dans ces territoires il y
a pas du tout un schéma binaire entre
dans le genre dans ce genre de question
bateau Hélène pesquine vous qui vous
intéressez beaucoup au territoire est-ce
que vous pensez que le numérique a un
effet sur la pauvreté pour la réduire
pour la rendre plus acceptable ou de ce
point de vue là ça sert pas grand chose
alors je suis pas sûr que le numérique
fasse le lien social qui peut être
attendu par les gens qui sont justement
éloignés des services publics moi ce que
je voudrais dire c'est pas plutôt par
rapport au choc récent et notamment à ce
qu'elle a généré le mouvement des gilets
jaunes c'est plutôt la transition
écologique qui génère ce sentiment de
classement nouveaux notamment de classe
moyenne en tout cas voilà de ménage
modest ce n'est pas très pauvre qui
ressentent que leur pouvoir d'achat
évolue à la baisse notamment et alors
c'est encore plus vrai aujourd'hui avec
les questions du prix de l'énergie qui
qui s'envole mais c'était déjà vrai un
moment on a essayé de taxer davantage
des carburants fossiles et en fait ces
chocs là ils ont moins d'effet sur des
populations très urbaines qui justement
comme on l'a dit ont plus accès ça aussi
de transport collectif et à d'autres et
à d'autres aménités dans la proximité
dans la densité urbaine donc il y a
encore une fois c'est des questions qui
sont
interprétés et ressentaient différemment
selon les catégories sociales auxquelles
on s'adresse mais en vérité enfin en
réalité dans les chiffres les gens les
plus pauvres ils sont en France à 60% de
l'écart-turbains
merci alors je vous invite maintenant à
voir cette carte de l'Insee concernant
le niveau de vie
[Musique]
alors selon cette carte de l'Insee selon
l'Insee le niveau de vie en France entre
1960 et 2020 est en évolution constante
certes il se stabilise
finalement c'est quoi ce niveau de vie
Hervé Le Bras et pourquoi les gens ont
le sentiment du contraire
et ça n'est pas que les journalistes qui
le disent mais quand vous interrogez les
gens et vous diront mais vous faites la
propagande je pense que il y a une
raison je vais me lancer dans un peu
psychologie quand même il y a une raison
je pense profonde c'est que
effectivement vous l'avez vu sur la
courbe le niveau de vie a beaucoup
augmenté jusque au début des années 2000
et puis il a ensuite assez peu évolué
très légèrement et au fond les la
situation dans laquelle on était c'était
de dire
ça va continuer à augmenter ça va et on
s'est retrouvé avec une stagnation donc
par rapport aux anticipations il y a une
grande déception et à nouveau c'est
aussi un des grandes idées de
Tocqueville sur ce quand il cherche à
expliquer la Révolution française il dit
mais comment se fait-il que il y a eu un
tel progrès au XVIIIe siècle il regarde
de près il dit oui mais à partir des
années 179
ça se stabilise ça n'augmente plus et
donc cette espèce d'élan l'idée que on
va vers des futurs de tous de plus en
plus glorieux paraît bloqués par et
arrêter je pense que c'est une des
raisons du du sentiment d'insatisfaction
c'est que on a l'impression que ça y est
c'est fini ça ne va plus augmenter
puisque le
schéma de l'Insee montre que le niveau
de vie et se stabilise quand même
stabilise mais peut-être que c'est par
rapport à la crise qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez pas est-ce que ça ça monte depuis
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec Hervé
Le
en fait on le voit au moment des
révolutions les révolutions sont pas
créées par une baisse de la croissance
du pouvoir d'achat elles sont plutôt
créés par une hausse parce que quand il
y a une transformation et quand il y a
un enrichissement il y a une question
qui est qui va gagner et j'ai travaillé
récemment sur l'Afrique sahélienne
après la région la plus pauvre du monde
et notamment le la zone du malice
Sénégal etc où il y a en ce moment une
offensive djihadiste extrêmement
extrêmement vive en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire les pays sont pas en
train de s'enrichir de s'appauver ils
sont en train de s'enrichir ils sont en
train de s'enrichir un petit peu et il y
a un changement de génération très
puissant parce qu'il y a une dynamique
démographique très forte et en fait
derrière le djihadisme il y a plein de
conflits il y a des conflits régionaux
il y a des conflits ethniques il y a des
conflits religieux il y a aussi un
conflit social et générationnel avec des
gens qui qui veulent avoir accès aux
richesses et à des richesses qui sont
des richesses nouvelles donc le
sentiment de pauvreté ou de déclassement
il est très compliqué à gérer il est il
est rarement assis sur la réalité il est
assis sur une perception et puis
toujours sur les autres on se compare
aux autres et on oublie sa situation
je vais vous donner la parole mais je
voudrais
que vous interveniez sur le sujet mais
en même temps que vous nous disiez sans
démagogie si le niveau de pauvreté est
le niveau de vie d'un point de vue
mondial
a aussi constamment augmenter et en gros
est-ce qu'il y a moins de pauvres dans
le monde et comment sa dernière question
je pense que le ressenti est dû à
l'hyperconsumérisme dans lequel nous
sommes et dans le côté social si par
exemple
j'ai un enfant de 14 ans qui va au
collège au lycée si son jeu pas c'est
ces chaussures de sport tous les six
mois alors que tous les autres copains
ont des Nike xxx il est considéré comme
étant pauvre donc aujourd'hui
malheureusement et d'ailleurs on l'a
bien vu dans les dans les gilets jaunes
c'était pas comme on l'avait très bien
dit les uns et les autres des pauvres
pauvres mais c'est des gens qui avaient
l'impression d'être déclasser parce que
par exemple l'enfant pouvait pas acheter
le l'Apple 14 ou l'Apple 13 je ne sais
pas combien d'années donc ça c'est ça
que je veux dire alors maintenant sur le
monde entier il y a eu durant 30 ans
depuis les 30 dernières années une
baisse SPECT populaire de la une baisse
de la pauvreté on est passé
en 1990 on était 30% de pauvres dans le
monde en
2012 c'était 14,3 % notamment à cause de
la Chine et avec la je vais y venir et
de la récemment 2019 c'était
7,1%. le problème c'est que cette
diminution est en train de s'arrêter
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une stagnation
pourquoi un en raison de l'accès au bien
public mondiaux
deux en raison du covid actuellement qui
a fait un certain nombre de peuples il y
a 100 millions de personnes qui sont
tombées dans la pauvreté en raison du
covid en raison aussi de la corruption
des pays qui est juste la plus grande
gangrène des pays pauvres et là puisque
ça augmente les coûts et ça diminue
l'accès à la santé et l'accès la justice
et a toujours ça dans les cycles
économiques il y a des il y a des
plateaux et il y a des montées il y a
des descentes des plateaux etc important
normal que avec des crises comme on a
connu qu'il y ait ces éléments
importants et beaucoup plus ennuyeux
c'est ce que la Banque mondiale appelle
la
le partage de la croissance
entre 2012 et 2015 si on prend les 40%
de personnes les plus pauvres dans un
pays en développement on s'est perçu que
au contraire l'augmentation de la
croissance l'augmentation de l'économie
l'augmentation des emplois
bénéficier aussi aux pauvres alors que
depuis 2015 malheureusement ça c'est
totalement en panne il faudrait savoir
d'ailleurs pourquoi et la dernière
inégalité elle est genre puisque c'est
des femmes qui sont aujourd'hui
franchement plus pauvres que les
inégalités
on n'arrive pas à atténuer les
inégalités et on va parler en détail
mais elle baisse qui nous voudrait vous
poser une question délicate d'ailleurs
si vous souhaitez pas y répondre vous
êtes libre
on parle de croissance
il y en a qui parle de décroissant il y
en a qui ça en parlant de postes
croissant finalement
le consumérisme c'est à la fois un
usage des riches un usage des pauvres et
je vais vous dire aujourd'hui
il y a une pensée qui consiste à dire
faisant de la pose croissance mais je
vais vous dire il y a des gens qui n'ont
plus que la croissance Jérôme Fourquet
dit par exemple je suis ce que je
consomme donc porter atteinte à ça
est-ce que vous constatez ce phénomène
là qui est à la fois humain social
économique culturelle je voudrais dire
plusieurs choses d'abord en rebondissant
sur ce que disait à l'instant on a vu
une réduction spectaculaire de la
pauvreté mais aussi une augmentation
spectaculaire des inégalités on va
parler des inégalités de troisième
partie de cette émission notamment ces
20 dernières années donc la pauvreté
ressentie entre guillemets elle est
réellement différente de ce qu'elle
pouvait être encore il y a 20 ou 30 ans
et si on parle de cette idée là moi
j'aime bien traduire le consommerisme en
émission de gaz à effet de serre je peux
vous dire que les 10% les plus riches
leur consommation de carbone par
habitant elle est beaucoup plus élevée
que les plus pauvres donc ils ont beau
avoir un accès à la consommation et
heureusement qui est un peu de pouvoir
d'achat c'est pas contestable et donc
souhaité accéder à la consommation
qu'effectivement dans nos sociétés
capitaliste contemporaine et très
valorisée mais en termes de masse
consommer et de défaits et notamment
d'impact environnemental sur les
ressources de la planète ça n'a rien à
voir avec ce que consomme non seulement
les 0,1% les plus riches mais même les
10% les plus riches et même en France
c'est très significatifs
près de 15 ou 20 ans pour les plus
riches donc c'est énormément d'écart
entre les capacités de consommation de
ces deux catégories sociales si on prend
encore une fois les décisives les plus
élevés et les plus faibles donc la
consommation oui ça fait partie de la
culture
occidentale aujourd'hui et peut-être
qu'à un moment donné il faudra la
questionner par rapport aux effets sur
les ressources qu'elle engendre et ces
impacts environnementaux et sociaux mais
on peut pas comparer le mode de
consommation des personnes modestes qui
comptent on l'a dit tout à l'heure qui
compte au jour le jour on a donné des
exemples très très concrets ce qu'elles
sont capables d'acheter pour ne pas se
sentir déclasser ou que leur famille ne
se sentent pas déplacées et ceux qui
finalement ne comptent pas puisque tout
est accessible et quel que soit le prix
et les fameuses baskets elles peuvent
coûter 5000 euros par aménage très riche
et si elle coûte 50 euros pour un
management c'est déjà difficile à
accepter non mais si vous prenez par
exemple les portables vous vous
apercevez que les gens en changent et
pas forcément au niveau en fonction de
leur niveau de vie
est-ce que vous pensez Hervé Le Bras
qu'on peut porter
atteinte à la consommation aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça n'est pas
ça n'engendrerait pas un retour de
flamme parce qu'on a poussé les gens à
consommer et en leur dirait en quelque
sorte ça constituerait une double peine
pour une pauvre lui dire consommer moins
oui déjà qui consomme il y en a déjà qui
consomment assez peu donc c'est surtout
oui je pense que
c'est très difficile de prévoir qu'elle
va être le ressenti c'est encore plus
difficile que de comprendre quelle est
la raison du ressenti donc je me
réserverai guère dans cette favorable à
une poste croissance à une décroissance
non je ne suis pas d'une certaine d'une
certaine manière je pense que des gens
font nous cinq qui sommes ici avons un
niveau de vie où ce terme de post
croissance n'a pas grand sens c'était ce
terme de poste
que nous sommes oui nous adressons à des
millions de téléspectateurs en ce que
pour les plus pauvres bien entendu le
mot croissance c'est toujours une
promesse donc ça sera très dur
effectivement pour la partie la plus
pauvre de la population de renoncer à ce
qui lui être au fond normal et qui lui
paraît faire partie de l'égalité
citoyenne particulièrement dans un pays
comme la France mais pas simplement la
France on voit que actuellement vous
parliez d'écologie on voit que devant la
menace de restriction de l'énergie
toutes les barrières sont en train de
sauter l'Allemagne
rouvre ses centrales à charbon la France
la France
comment dire paye pour la consommation
d'essence pour le gaz donc d'une
certaine manière effectivement ça va
être très dur et les pots cassés ça sera
du côté de du côté de l'écologie
parce que le mot à la mode en ce moment
c'est sobriété mais il faut comprendre
que la sobriété choisie celle que nous
on peut accepter c'est à dire de faire
un petit effort de consommer moins
éventuellement ou différemment de
choisir des alternatives à ce qu'on
avait l'habitude de consommer pour être
moins impactant pour l'environnement on
peut pas du tout demander la même chose
à déménage qui ont une sobriété
permanente qui est totalement vos
contraintes et si on est bien d'accord
on va pas de gens très pauvres ces gens
là ils font des choix ils sont sombres
je voudrais juste terminer là-dessus il
y a certainement dans cette logique de
je sais pas il faut si vous l'appeler
décroissance mais en tout cas de
meilleure mesure des impacts de la
consommation il faut
identifier ce qui correspond en gros à
aux biens essentiels et donc au socle de
bien auquel doivent pouvoir accéder la
majorité des Français notamment ceux qui
en ont qui ont l'accès le plus difficile
et ça peut être aussi logique de
tarification progressive d'accéder à un
paquet de bien nécessaire et utile à une
population fragile avant de se poser la
question de savoir s'il faut qu'elle
consomme moins enfin on est quand même
sur des populations qui sont contraintes
d'être sobre sur des
cultures et dire que vous pouvez pas
vous exprimer pour les pauvres et que
vous apportez une expertise bourgeoise
je ne le ferai pas mais néanmoins
à vous de Saint Philippe Douste Blazy
qui voyageait qui allait souvent aux
États-Unis est-ce que vous pensez qu'en
regardant avec une hit live les pays
pauvres est-ce que ils sont sensibles à
ces notions de décroissance etc où il
peut ou y considère qu'il faut les
laisser vivre en consommant
d'abord comme viennent très bien de le
dire Hélène je veux dire vous pouvez pas
dire à des gens qui sont de la sobriété
obligatoire pour eux que ils vont y
rester c'est pas possible vous pouvez
toujours donner un espoir aux personnes
d'autant plus que internet leur montre
tout de suite vous n'avez pas du net
live mais là je voudrais en dire un mot
parce que au fond c'est la pire chose
qui peut arriver ce sujet qui moi m'a
fait ouvrir ce fond aux Nations Unies
c'est que
les gens extrêmement pauvres les femmes
extrêmement pauvres dans le monde y
compris d'ailleurs parfois en Occident
ne mange pas suffisamment de protéines
de poisson et de viande
idem parce que le poisson et la viande
c'est cher alors nous on s'en rend pas
compte peut-être obligatoirement mais le
poisson et la viande c'est cher si vous
ne prenez pas quand une femme enceinte
ne prend pas de viande et de poisson
brutalement elle manque de vitamines de
protéines elle est enceinte la grossesse
se passe très bien la première année de
l'enfant se passe très bien la deuxième
année se passe très bien le jour des
trois ans
il y a 30% de quotient intellectuel en
moins 30% de connexion des neurones en
moins donc est-ce que vous vous rendez
compte le fait que non seulement un port
vit comme pauvre c'est à dire que c'est
extrêmement dur et en plus son enfant va
avoir tout de suite un problème cérébral
la viande c'est très dur de le dire
comme ça sauf que maintenant il faut le
dire parce que ça veut dire que la
pauvreté engendre la pauvreté et que ces
pays n'arriveront pas à s'en sortir
quand je vous aurais dit qu'il y a 42%
d'enfants comme cela en Afrique
subsaharienne personne ne le dit lorsque
on parle du cancer on parle du sida tout
le monde en parle la personne tout le
monde s'en fout et donc on a monté un
fond là dessus et avec Bill Gates avec
le président Macron d'ailleurs et dedans
et avec un certain nombre de personnes à
l'Unicef aux Nations Unies onufam parce
que c'est la pire des injustices vous
arrivez parce que votre maman est pauvre
vous
dans le monde
avec vous ne pouvez pas comprendre
se réduit au niveau mondial j'avais pu
maintenant il était vrai jusqu'en
2015 2016 aujourd'hui avec le covid d'un
côté les conflits parce que dans les
pays ont entendu non mais conflits le
Yémen c'est la famille
[Musique]
alors on va en venir quand même au sujet
qui fâche parce que les beaux discours
c'est bien les bonnes intentions c'est
bien le progressisme c'est très bien
mais finalement on se rend compte que
les inégalités sociales se maintiennent
l'angle alors elle se malgré toutes les
politiques elle se maintiennent dans le
temps et il y a même une aggravation de
disparité entre les plus pauvres et les
plus riches alors qui est responsable
les États les banques les entreprises
les circuits financiers
Hervé Le Bras qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de ces cette institutionnalisation
des
inégalités sociales malgré tout ce qui
est fait c'est la même chose pour les
inégalités que pour la pauvreté si je
vous montrais
mais la courbe de l'INSEE pour les
inégalités et exactement la même pour
l'évolution des de l'inégalité en France
qu'on la mesure il y a plusieurs façons
de la mesurer je vais pas vous ennuyer
avec l'indice de Viny les rapports de
déciles etc
la il y a une baisse de l'inégalité de
tous ces indices à peu près au début des
années 2000 et puis depuis ça bouge très
peu ça un peu augmenté avec la crise des
subprimes pendant deux trois ans et puis
ça y est on a retrouvé le niveau mais il
y a pas contrairement à ce qu'on pense
il y a aucune preuve qui est une
augmentation des inégalités et vous
devez
vous demande pardon mais en question au
niveau de l'héritage par exemple du
patrimoine ça augmente considérablement
pour les pour le patrimoine vous avez
raison les inégalités trop de 1960
en 1960 à 60% des ménages qui ont un
patrimoine parce qu'ils ont hérité tout
à fait non mais vous avez raison pour le
patrimoine le patrimoine a évolué assez
différemment de la croissance économique
particulièrement en France mais je
voulais revenir sur le monde c'est un
économiste François bourguignon a montré
que alors que les inégalités avaient
plutôt tendance dans un nombre de pays à
augmenter quand on regardait l'inégalité
on la mesure et la même manière mais
dans le monde entier on mettait tous les
tous les habitants du monde ensemble
elle diminue relativement rapidement du
fait que il y a une égalité entre pays
mais à l'intérieur de chaque pays au
contraire on voit dans des pays comme
les États-Unis ou comme la
Grande-Bretagne les inégalités
augmentent donc il y a des paradoxes ce
qu'on appelle des paradoxes d'échelle si
vous voulez selon l'échelle que vous
prenez vous pouvez dire ça augmente ou
ça diminue si je peux permettre
concernant l'extrême pauvreté l'extrême
pauvreté dans les pays il y a une
inégalité aussi il faut le comprendre
entre les pays comme l'Asie du de l'Est
de chine japon Vietnam et l'Asie du
Sud-Est d'un côté où la diminution de la
pauvreté a été extrêmement importante et
puis l'Afrique subsaharienne qui stagne
avec 42% de la population donc quand on
parle de ces pays dit pauvres il y a en
fait il respecter les différents
géographiques tout à fait alors avec
vous parce qu'il en va poursuivre ce
débat Philippe Douste Blazy disait qu'au
niveau de du monde fallait pas
simplement voir les inégalités en
matière de revenus mais il fallait voir
comment ça se joue en au niveau de la
santé la question que je vous pose vous
qui vous intéressez beaucoup au
territoire
qu'est-ce qu'il faut sur quoi il faut
travailler essentiellement l'éducation
la santé la sécurité la justice le
logement parce que c'est très bien on
parle aujourd'hui d'adapter les
logements aux normes écologiques les
transports etc mais devant cette
kyrielle de facteurs discriminants c'est
quoi les priorités pas vos priorités au
ministère mais les priorités que vous
pensez
indispensable pour réduire ces
inégalités alors je pense qu'il y a déjà
un problème de du tableau qu'on renvoie
quand la société ren que parfois les
personnalités politiques renvoient de la
pauvreté en France et ailleurs dire mais
je m'intéresse plus à la France pour
rebondir sur ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure on a parfois tendance à assimilé
les ménages pauvres à déménager ça ça
peut arriver on pouvait par exemple on
compare la fraude fiscale et la fraude
sociale alors qu'en termes de montant
absolument rien à voir et donc on a
parfois tendance à stigmatiser les
ménages pauvres comme étant étant un peu
responsable de leur état de pauvre et de
pauvreté et donc ça ça joue quand même
sur la manière dont on prend en charge
des politiques publiques
donc en donnant une image fausse de ce
qu'est une réalité voilà on accède au
monde dans une famille pauvre ou dans
une famille riche dans une famille
migrantes ou immigré éventuellement qui
de toute façon n'a pas la même chance au
démarrage que d'autres qui ont hérité ou
qui ont un patrimoine plus important il
y a cette image qui est renvoyée sur la
catégorie des classes les plus
populaires dans la société et donc la
manière dont on est prêt ou pas à être
solidaire avec elle je donne un autre
exemple qui a été un peu évoqué tout à
l'heure sur la politique de la vie un
sujet que je connais bien moi aussi
c'est à dire les crédits de l'État qui
sont donnés au territoire au quartier
difficile ou au quartier de banlieue on
va dire des grandes villes pour aider
les gens à s'intégrer à sortir de la
pauvreté notamment on dit souvent que
c'est un puissant fond que finalement
cet argent ce pognon dingue des versets
sur ces quartiers et qui sont toujours
pauvres mais en fait ça a été très bien
dit ils sont toujours pauvres parce que
c'est là que se concentre la pauvreté en
France c'est que les gens qui accèdent
au logement ou ce parfum des logements
très dégradés mais en tout cas qui
arrive à s'installer s'installe d'abord
dans ces quartiers donc ceux qui peuvent
ressortir ensemble et évidemment qu'il y
a toujours besoin de mettre l'accent et
le coût de projecteur sur ces quartiers
pour éviter aux gens de rester dans des
systèmes
stabilisés disons de pauvreté et donc on
a besoin pour que les politiques
publiques de solidarité soit efficaces
de sortir aussi un peu de ces idées
reçues et de et de d'objectiver
finalement la question
non pas de vous contre dire mais de
demander à qui mêle car oui s'il est
d'accord sur la globalité de ces
politiques publiques ou plutôt vous
seriez favorable à ce que on part plutôt
des besoins des habitants plutôt que de
déverser de l'argent sur des grandes
politiques
alors je pourrais dans le sens de ce que
disait Hélène juste un exemple la
Seine-Saint-Denis on parle de protection
sociale c'est le 8e département
contributeurs au financement de la
protection sociale on compte par
habitant c'est le dernier receveur et
pourtant c'est le département le plus
jeune le plus pauvre et là où il y a le
plus d'immigrés en France parce que la
protection sociale c'est pas seulement
le RSA c'est aussi toute la santé c'est
aussi toutes les retraites et le premier
département qui reçoit la protection
sociale c'est là où Eric Zemmour a fait
sa meilleur score c'est dans le Var
donc les idées reçues
c'est ce qui explique cette réalité sauf
que la protection sociale c'est la
solidarité nationale et c'est
essentiellement d'ailleurs
financé par le travail donc dans les
départements il y a énormément de jeunes
et très peu de retraités en fait on
reçoit très peu de la protection sociale
par contre on contribue énormément ça
donne cet exemple de la
Seine-Saint-Denis ensuite l'accent
l'argent qu'on met sur la politique de
la ville c'est en fait essentiellement
sur les bâtiments
et donc on a effectivement un peu plus
d'argent pour les bâtiments mais il faut
faire attention aussi parce qu'il y a un
effet de loop très fort parce que la
politique de la ville elle est
territorialisée donc on compte combien
on met d'argent et c'est de la Réno ce
qu'on appelle la rénovation urbaine la
rénovation et puis il y a aussi un peu
de destruction mais il y a que pour les
quartiers politiques de la ville qu'on
compte combien on met d'argent pour la
rénovation urbaine donc il y a un peu
d'argent de l'État mais en fait très peu
puis après il y a de l'argent il y a de
la dette et puis il y a du 1% logement
donc en fait déjà pour les bâtiments il
y a pas beaucoup plus d'argent si on
comptait toute la rénovation urbaine
toute la rénovation des HLM partout en
France en fait on se rendrait compte que
l'argent de la politique de la ville il
est en fait très très faible et puis la
deuxième chose pardon c'est que
effectivement on met cet argent sur les
bâtiments et sur les habitants en fait
on en met moins qu'ailleurs c'est ça le
paradoxe je vous dis il manque un
milliard d'euros par an juste de
fonctionnaires dans les quartiers
politiques de la ville et on croit que
on déverse plein d'argent et que tous
ces gens là sont des assistés mais je
vous dis deux choses un il finance plus
qu'il ne reçoivent vous l'avez section
sociale et de il reçoivent moins de
services publics que les autres et donc
ça fait pas vraiment d'eux des assister
ce sont les perdants et pourquoi ce sont
des perdants parce que ce sont des
pauvres dans le débat politique il y a
un conflit de répartition et ce qui
gagne c'est toujours les riches dans les
enquêtes de l'Union européenne le
sentiment d'insécurité le plus fort en
France est-ce que vous faites le lien
entre pauvreté et insécurité Hélène
pesqui moi personnellement je le fais
pas mais d'autres comme moi le font
notamment dans certains quartiers qui
sont stigmatisés pour des taux
d'insécurité élevés si je peux juste
dire
que le recours aux aides sociales est
faible chez les très pauvres donc en
fait on parle de solidarité que voilà on
donnerait beaucoup pour aider les
pauvres à sortir de la pauvreté en
réalité il y a 50% des très pauvres qui
ne recourent pas aux aides sociales et
donc pauvret
insécurité et souvenez-vous ce que
disait Laurent Bouvet l'insécurité
culturelle c'est quelque chose de très
important oui mais plus plus sceptique
les Revenge je voudrais juste en termes
de conclusion faire une remarque c'est
que quand on fait une carte de France
des inégalités c'est pratiquement la
même carte que celle de la pauvreté
autrement dit c'est les régions les plus
pauvres qui sont les plus inégales
autrement dit la source principale de
l'inégalité c'est la pauvreté c'est très
bien et sur pauvreté et sécurité que
vous faites un lien non dans les
enquêtes c'est très compliqué parce que
le sentiment d'insécurité presque aussi
aberrant que le même le sentiment par
rapport à l'immigration c'est à dire que
ceux qui ont le plus fort sentiment
d'insécurité c'est dans les zones les
plus rurales où il se produit le moins
de problèmes de sécurité donc là on
entre à nouveau dans une série de
fantasmes difficiles
de stablasi sur la sécurité
et pauvreté
au niveau mondial il y a un cercle
infernal entre pauvreté
humiliation
conflit guère et on repart de la
pauvreté donc ça c'est autre chose mais
c'est vrai que les pays les plus pauvres
sont souvent beaucoup plus en conflits
que les autres juste un dernier mot je
pense que les biens publics mondiaux
l'eau potable la santé etc ne peut pas
être réglé uniquement pour le
capitalisme Dieu sait si je le suis pour
le capitalisme mais sur ces sujets là il
faut inventer quelque chose parce que si
on n'a pas rationnaire rien à la poche
on peut pas avoir de l'eau potable on
est bien d'accord
vous avez été ministre et à l'époque
d'un président qui s'appelait Jacques
Chirac je crois et qui considérait que
pour certains biens publics mondiaux il
fallait les sortir du marché exactement
pour laquelle nous avons créé un euro
par billet d'avion ça fait 7 milliards à
la sortie et ça fait se permet de
soigner 80% des enfants atteint le sida
dans le monde c'est ça montre bien qu'à
un moment donné pour ces sujets là pas
pour les autres je suis contre
l'hyperprotectionnisme je dis simplement
que pour ces sujets il faut inventer un
nouveau système sinon il y aura toujours
des pauvres qui n'ont rien à la poche
qui peuvent pas prendre de l'eau potable
alors pour vous qui met le car oui
est-ce que la pauvreté génère de
l'insécurité et est-ce que l'insécurité
s'accouple à la pauvreté je veux dire
une chose très simple les premières
victimes de l'insécurité ce sont les
pauvres donc une fois qu'on a dit ça en
fait il y a pas de conflit entre entre
eux et l'insécurité il y a pas de
conflit entre les gilets jaunes les
habitants des quartiers il y a un
problème commun et il faut lutter contre
et une façon lutter contre c'est de
mettre des forces de l'ordre dans les
quartiers pauvres ce qui n'est
absolument pas le cas il y a
proportionnellement au taux d'homicide
30 fois moins de force de l'ordre en
Seine-Saint-Denis que dans le
département de l'Indre ce qui est
complètement fou mais qui explique
toujours la même manière les pauvres ont
peu de capacité d'actions politiques et
dans les départements plus installés où
il y a des notables etc ils sont
capables de faire des recours au
ministère de l'Intérieur
je vais maintenant vous présenter une
bibliographie alors Hervé Le Bras vous
êtes un peu à contretemps de cette
émission on parle des pauvres et vous
dites se sentir mal dans une France qui
va bien donc on est des plinthes ça date
d'il y a deux ans
se sentir mal dans une France qui va qui
va mal non non je pense je continue à
penser que comparé au reste du monde et
même ce qui était le cas dans mon livre
c'était une comparaison avec l'Union
européenne on est un des pays qui s'en
sort le mieux à beaucoup de points de
vue
voilà
alors Hakim El Karoui c'est pas
forcément un livre qui est lié à
l'émission mais c'est un livre que vous
avez publié les militants du djihad
portrait d'une génération je signalerai
votre enquête institut Montaigne sur la
pauvreté notamment au niveau des
périphéries de la France périphérique et
des banlieues mais là-dessus il y a on
peut relier ça et pauvreté ce serait
dans ma bougie en partie mais seulement
en partie le vrai sujet il est
identitaire le vrai sujet est
identitaire alors Philippe Douste Blazy
dans la Revue des Deux Mondes les
publier un article qui s'appelle
l'épuisement français vous avez
également écrit un ouvrage sur la
solidarité sauvera le monde
en quelque sorte vous avez encore
l'ambition de sauver le monde
personnellement mais avec vos fondations
en tout cas celles dans lesquelles vous
œuvrez mais je pense beaucoup que en
tout cas on est sur unie le premier
objectif du développement durable c'est
de diminuer l'extrême pauvreté à 3% en
2030 je pense qu'on y arrivera pas mais
les inégalités peuvent faire en sorte
que le monde devienne de plus en plus
dangereux c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai écrit ça merci alors Hélène
pesquine les publications du Q4 de tous
les sujets concernant les territoires
mais là on a un ouvrage important la
ville accueillante voilà c'est vous
venez pour défendre la ville qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez en dire qui est tiré
d'une enquête d'une recherche qui a été
conduite sur le camp de Grande-Synthe
donc le camp de migrants de
Grande-Synthe qui a été
institutionnalisée grâce à un projet de
médecin du monde notamment et donc qui a
accueilli pendant plusieurs années des
migrants qui sont partants on va dire
pour l'Angleterre donc dans cette région
de de la France qui a été très soumise à
ces arrivées de migrants et donc le
projet ne vise pas à dire si c'est bien
ou pas bien de les accueillir mais de
constater qu'ils sont sur le territoire
français et que des élus notamment sont
obligés de compter avec eux et donc ça
raconte ce récit de l'installation dans
ce camp spécialisé de migrants à Calais
à côté de Calais avec malheureusement
issue de un peu dramatique puisque le
camp a brûlé deux années après la
recherche mais en tout cas le récit est
très intéressant en tout cas les récits
sont toujours très importants parce que
c'est un témoignage qui demeure merci
Madame merci messieurs d'avoir participé
à cette émission merci à l'équipe de LCP
qui a permis de la réaliser et je vous
laisse je vous soumets en même temps
cette citation de Sacha Guitry la
pauvreté assez franchise l'opulence à sa
gêne
[Musique]